[MUSIC PLAYING]
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
Hello, everyone,
and welcome to Going
Further with FlatBuffers.
So this talk is about
advanced users of FlatBuffers,
so I won't go into details about
what FlatBuffers actually is.
But if you've never heard
of it, let me give you
the executive summary.
FlatBuffers is a cross-platform
serialization library that
is all about memory efficiency.
If you're going to remember
just one thing about it,
let it be that it
allows in-place access
of serialized data without
first parsing or unpacking it.
And it does all this while still
allowing the data to evolve.
It is strongly typed
through schemas,
and of course, we support
lots of languages,
and import, export to JSON.
It is used in game engines,
internally at Google,
and externally, for
example, in Cocos-2Dx.
It is also widely used
outside of games, for example
at Facebook and Netflix.
So today, I'll be talking
about seven advanced ways
in which you can get
more out of FlatBuffers.
First up, we have schemaless
FlatBuffers, otherwise
known as FlexBuffers.
So FlatBuffers,
generally, are a great way
to store strongly
typed data, but what
if you need to store
data for which you
can't define a schema yet?
So with
[? FlatBuffers, ?] we took
all the advantages
of FlatBuffers,
and we turned them into
self-describing data structure.
It still has the in-place
access without parsing,
so it's a similar speed
advantage to FlatBuffers.
You can share keys and values
to get big space savings,
compared to JSON.
And the serializer
automatically finds the smallest
possible [? representations ?]
for all your values,
often down to a single
byte, and you can nest them
inside FlatBuffers.
So you can choose the most
appropriate data representation
for all your data.
And on this slide,
we have an example
of creating a FlexBuffer, on
the fly, without the schema,
and without having to create
any data structures first.
Now, don't worry if the code
looks a little bit scary.
There's also version
doesn't use lambdas.
Then you can read it
directly from the buffer,
with random access and no
memory allocation whatsoever.
FlatBuffers also has
in-place binary search.
The way this works--
if you have a vector of tables,
you can mark one of the fields
as a key and have the vector
sorted during serialization.
This allows you to do fast,
binary search look ups directly
on the buffer, without having
to create any map or dictionary
structures.
Next, in place mutation.
So serialized data is
not typically something
you want to modify
after the fact.
But FlatBuffers allows
you to do so anyway.
This kind of makes
sense, since a FlatBuffer
is something that can replace
a traditional object tree.
So with this feature, you can
use it to store values, too,
and then once
you're done with it,
you can [? write ?]
it back to disk,
without having to do any
reserialization of the data.
Next, reflection allows you
to work with serialized data
in ways that go beyond
the simple read write API.
For one, it allows you to run
a loaded schema at runtime
and inspect it programmatically.
It also allows in place
mutation of more complex data
structures, like
strings and tables.
As you can see from it-- as you
can maybe see from the sample
code--
binary schema is implemented
using FlatBuffers itself,
using the same
generated code API
to access the schema,
which is all very meta.
We also have a
traditional object API.
There are times when
a classical object
tree is the best
representation for your data,
and none of the previous
methods are sufficient.
In that case, FlatBuffers can
generate code for you that
turns these buffers
into idiomatic C++.
It's not as fast as
using buffers in place,
but if you happen to
need it, then it's
better than writing
it all by hand.
And now for something
completely different.
GRPC is Google's open
source RPC library,
and now, FlatBuffers works
out of the box with GRPC.
So you can specify
your RPC in the schema,
and have all the glue
code generated for it.
And last, and maybe
least, to make migration
from Protocol Buffers
to FlatBuffers
a little bit easier, we
now have an automatic way
to translate Protocol Buffer
schemas into FlatBuffers.
And that's all I
have for you today.
For more information
on FlatBuffers,
please check out this URL,
or just come chat to me
afterwards.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]